AstraZeneca may be able to help.
EVERYONE IN AMERICA IS
GRIEVING FOR YOU.
PLEASE STAND.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
[ APPLAUSE ]
>> Laura: INCREDIBLY MOVING
MOMENT LAST NIGHT AT THE
STATE OF THE UNION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP CONSOLING
THE PARENTS OF TWO TEENAGE
GIRLS.
POLICE SAY THAT NISA MICKENS
AND KAYLA CUEVAS WERE CHASED
DOWN AND BRUTALLY MURDERED
BY MS-13 GANG MEMBERS IN
LONG ISLAND IN NEW YORK IN
2016.
THREE OF THE FOUR PEOPLE
CHARGED IN THE MURDERS ARE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS.
PRESIDENT TRUMP HONORED NISA
AND KAYLA LAST NIGHT BY
INVITING THEIR PARENTS TO
THE SPEECH.
WE REACHED OUT TO NISA'S
PARENTS ELIZABETH ALVARADO
AND ROBERT MICKENS AND BOTH
ARE KIND ENOUGH TO JOIN US
AND SHARE THEIR THOUGHTS ON
THE EVENING AND THEIR
REACTION TO THAT MOMENT.
TO BOTH OF YOU, I THOUGHT A
LOT ABOUT YOU BOTH TODAY IN
TO SAY FOR MY LISTENING
AUDIENCE ON RADIO AND I KNOW
ALL THE VIEWERS ON FOX, YOU
KNOW, NO WORDS CAN EXPRESS
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR BEING
BRAVE ENOUGH TO COME ON THE
SHOW AND TALK TO US.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
>> OH, YOU'RE WELCOME.
>> Laura: I WANT TO FIRST
STATE OF THE UNION SPEECH.
SO MANY POLITICIANS HAVEN'T
REALLY CONFRONTED WHAT MS-13
HAS DONE TO AMERICAN
HARD HIT IN 2016 AND 2017 BY
MS-13.
WHAT WAS IT LIKE TO BE
INVITED?
>> IT WAS DEFINITELY AN
HONOR.
AND, YOU KNOW, THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE WOULD --
IF WE WAS ASKED TO DO IT
AGAIN, WE WOULD DEFINITELY
DO IT?
>> YEAH, WE WOULD.
IT WAS OVERWHELMING.
>> Laura: GO AHEAD.
>> I'M SORRY.
IT WAS VERY OVERWHELMING AND
THERE TO SEE HIM.
IT WAS AN HONOR TO SEE HIM.
>> Laura: AND YOU MET WITH
HIM BEFORE THE STATE OF THE
UNION SPEECH BRIEFLY.
AND WHAT WAS THAT LIKE?
>> IT WAS GOOD.
>> EXCUSE ME.
YOU KNOW, WHEN WE WALKED
INTO HIS OFFICE, IT WAS LIKE
BREATH-TAKING.
AND I HAD LISA'S PEN
AND I HAD LISA'S PIN ON ME.
I ASKED HIM IF HE COULD TAKE
IT FOR A GIFT.
IT.
AND HE TOOK PICTURES WITH ME
WITH IT.
AND I -- YOU KNOW, HE IS
VERY GENUINE.
VERY NICE PRESIDENT.
I REALLY AM HAPPY THAT I MET
HIM.
FIND OUT THAT SO MANY PEOPLE
IN THE ROOM, THEY ARE MOSTLY
DEMOCRATS, DID NOT STAND UP
WHEN YOU WERE RECOGNIZED AND
WHEN YOUR DAUGHTER WAS
RECOGNIZED LAST NIGHT.
>> WELL, I THOUGHT IT WAS
VERY DISRESPECTFUL FOR THE
SIMPLE FACT THE DEMOCRATS
WHO WERE THERE THAT DID NOT
STAND UP, THEY WERE
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
AND TO AMERICANS' LIVES.
IT'S NOT RIGHT, YOU KNOW.
REGARDLESS OF HOW THEY FEEL
ABOUT THE PRESIDENT, THEY
LOVED ONE.
>> Laura: THERE WAS A WOMAN
ON ANOTHER CABLE CHANNEL
EARLIER TODAY AND, AGAIN, I
TRIED TO PUT MYSELF IN YOUR
AFTER THIS AMAZING MOMENT
WHERE SO MANY OF US WERE
LITERALLY CRYING WITH YOU
>> SPEECH TONIGHT IN WHICH
HE MAKES IT SOUND LIKE THE
BIGGEST ISSUE IN THE UNITED
STATES, THE BIGGEST THREAT
IS MS-13, A GANG NOBODY THAT
DOESN'T WATCH FOX NEWS HAS
EVER HEARD OF SO THEY FELT
LIKE THEY ARE THE BIGGEST
THREAT.
>> Laura: ELIZABETH, LIKE
MS-13 IS ANY BIG DEAL.
>> I HAVE NO WORDS.
I MEAN, THESE ARE GANG
LIKE THAT.
IT'S UNACCEPTABLE.
I DON'T WANT IT TO HAPPEN TO
ANYBODY ELSE'S FAMILY.
BUT, SOMETHING NEEDS TO BE
DONE.
AND I WON'T STOP DOING WHAT
I'M DOING UNTIL EVERYTHING
TURNS OUT RIGHT.
I CAN ONLY HOPE AND PRAY
THAT WHOEVER -- ANY GANG
MEMBERS, PLEASE, STOP THE
HOW MUCH MORE BLOOD DO WE
HAVE TO SHED.
>> Laura: BEFORE WE START
ENFORCING OUR BORDERS, THEY
SHOULD NEVER BE IN THIS
COUNTRY IN THE FIRST PLACE.
IF THEY WEREN'T IN THIS
COUNTRY IN THE FIRST PLACE,
YOUR DAUGHTER WOULD STILL BE
ALIVE TODAY.
THAT'S WHAT MAKES MY BLOOD
BOIL.
ROBERT AND ELIZABETH, THANK
YOU.
I KNOW WE ARE GOING IT CHECK
BACK WITH YOU.
I KNOW WOULD GOING TO WISH
YOU ALL THE BEST.
THANK YOU FOR SPENDING TIME
THANK YOU FOR HAVING US.
LIKE I SAID, IT'S AN HONOR.